il ya quelques jours anastasia salvi
fraîchement élue miss franche-comté
annoncé sur les réseaux sociaux renoncer
à son titre sans fournir plus
d'explications
je ne pourrai malheureusement pas
poursuivre l'aventuré miss franche comté
je tiens à présenter mes excuses à vous
qui avez voté pour moi très vite les
raisons qui ont motivé cette décision
exploser au grand jour des photos
dénudées de la jeune femme
datant de 2010 est ont refait leur
apparition des clichés artistiques pris
dans le cadre d'un concours
international pour deux marques de
coiffure des photos loin d'être choquant
mais qui vont à l'encontre du règlement
miss france un règlement qui stipule que
les candidates doivent déclarer avant
leur participation au concours toutes
photos dénudées aujourd'hui la jeune
femme avoue qu'elle a été virée poussé
vers la sortie par les équipes du
concours et que son message de démission
a été rédigé par le comité on a adressé
un texte a publié sur internet si je
voulais le modifier je devais le faire
valider je les passais tel quel j'étais
effondrée avec le sentiment d'avoir été
trahis une affaire qui n'est pas un cas
isolé
il y a quelques jours ce sont des
internautes qui ont tenté de mettre en
péril la victoire de naïma des soutes au
titre de miss saint martin saint
barthélémy 2020 en effet plusieurs
lettres anonymes ont été envoyés au
comité miss france pour dénoncer les
photos sexy qu aurait caché certaines
candidates un comportement de
dénonciation que ça roule yada
directrice artistique du comité miss
saint martin saint barthélémy ne
cautionne pas il n'y aura donc pas de
destitution de name c'est inconcevable
pour la simple raison que quoi qu'il
advienne à emma est et restera miss
saint martin saint barthélémy
deux poids deux mesures à quelques jours
d'intervalle au sein du comité alors
viré de miss france pour des photos sexy
jockey ou pas choqué à dire merci à
damien mercereau qui a nous a donné
beaucoup d'infos là dessus dans mes
morceaux de tv mag
gilles verdez choqué pourquoi anastasia
on attend votre avis on va laisser la
photo comme ça vous nous dites cela dit
c'est pour cette photo pour ses photos
voilà qu'elle a été destitué elle m'a
tout expliqué anastasia cela vous l'avez
au terrain j'ai discuté avant tout se
faisait plus eu envie d'enflammer
stadium voilà que michel cymes et l'iran
elle est très marquée on lui a brisé son
rêve et c'est un véritable scandale vais
vous expliquer pourquoi en 2015 elle a
gagné un prix d'élégance
elle a été repérée par un coiffeur le
coiffeur officiel du comité miss franche
comté de fabio salsa exactement elle a
fait ensuite elle a fait ensuite des
photos avec lui et pour le comité a été
prévenue savait à aimer ces photos les
appliquer les a commenté c'était près
sous l'égide du comité bien les prêts
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui dans l'hérault
on lui reproche ses photos n'étaient su
est connu de tout le monde fabio salsa
avait craqué sur eilat sur lui ont dit
qu'elle a menti
on dit que c'est une honte c'est faux on
dit que les photos sont inappropriées
c'est faux c'était sous l'égide du
comité c'était sookie l'égide du comité
c'est absolument scandaleux et je
demande c'est une victime
elle doit être réhabilité syrie alors
vous n'êtes pas jocketty finalement
alors effectivement et d'après ce que
dit anastasia oui sylvie tellier et la
dengue est rationnel anne laure vouillot
été on dit que non non il n'y avait rien
de contraire au règlement
ces clichés étaient bons mais que comme
l avait menti elle a menti et que voilà
c'est ça c'est ce que je dis c'est que
soi-disant comme elle a menti et qu'elle
a dissimulé ses photos c'est pour ça
qu'elle a été sanctionné alors qu
effectivement j la raison elle avait mis
ses photos sur instagram et
l'organisation de miss france où l'on
avait leaké ces photos et aujourd'hui
elle dit qu'elle se fait harceler par le
comité par fabio sa fille lui demande de
rendre son écharpe de rendre ces cadeaux
et apparemment la déléguée régionale
mais arrêtez lui aurait dit maintenant
tu vas te faire lyncher il faut que tu
tu enlèves des réseaux sociaux et part
en vacances d'accord d'aller à une
victime des crédits obtenus en léger pas
château
voilà pour aider à localiser voilà c'est
tout j'essaie de réaliser la faute à
cette vitalité alors sylvie tu te dis
attention
alors je vous le dis si vous ne venez
maintenant si c'est la belle soeur de
jean pierre cattenoz à dire que votre
femme et la soeur de sylvie tellier donc
en rond dans la famille donc est ce que
ça veut dire
on va voir si les langues de bois parce
que vous n'êtes pas ce qui fait ça ce
que j'avais peur de ne pas être choqué
parce qu'il ya un règlement
ça nous rappelle soeur alors alors pas
du tout je peux pas l'avoir mais que ce
soit bien clair
non mais je peux pas mais je le regrette
encore chez les sabres et maintenant
laissez pas votre femme c'est la soeur
de sa femme qui est divine à comparer à
elle jeu mais j'ai le j'ai le droit de
dire que ma femme est beaucoup plus
belle que ça je crois que c'est dans le
coeur de l'accord allaient à l'épreuve
sylvie aussi moi je moi je trouve pas
persuadé que ça va être un horrible ans
à l'époque des miss france mais c'est
vrai d'onal quoi mais c'est la guerre
dans les ardennes il en met en scène
jean la police et tu nous regardes mon
jardin et une palette jean-marc je
prends ça pourrait vite alors moi je
l'investis pas du tout maintenant si on
sait en quoi il parle car ces permis de
me juger chacun connaisse mais si ce que
je sais pas si je la connais pas mais
elle s'est permis de le juger si tu veux
ce que de suisse quand j'ai rencontré sa
soeur c'est pas bien de sortir avec
quelqu'un de la télé non je dis je suis
bien content que la télé la fasse
bouffer apparemment oui c'est pas des
bas mais sais-tu c'est pour moi ça c'est
pas c'est pas le problème n'avait jamais
rencontré votre boxeur non mais
j'aimerais bien discuter avec elle
m'apparaît me connaît très bien
non mais bon je vais pourquoi mais là on
va la voir peut-être bientôt balle et sa
visite par mariage c'est la ocz
peut-être pas bien c'est les missiles
faut pas voir les niches en l'air et
comme je vais à la plage torse nu lacé
à temps plein tout l'été on s'est régalé
les papilles de vos votes à votre
mariage
non non on va se marier je suis future
marée noire et bientôt mais le veuillez
ou pas vous êtes invités s'ils s'étaient
dit moi personnellement je n'invite pas
mais si ma future femme de là j'étais
bien sûr elle viendra sans problème leur
parviendra pas on ne va pas assez je
pense élégant mais je trouve beaucoup
vraiment dommage que cette cette
personne a des miss qui a été pour sa
voix la bastille un règlement ok mais
y'a rien comme je pense qu'il faudrait
remettre à niveau un petit peu les miss
et revenir un peu en 2021 on est plus en
ouais enfin c'est sylvie tellier qu'il
faut changer anastasia ça c'est vrai que
sylvie tellier et la belle-soeur de
leurs baskets c'est la soeur de sa femme
sur les api un cto et apparemment dont
la famille est une entente cordiale
vous serez tout servir les repas de
famille on a envie d'y aller
vous êtes invités madika alors vous qui
était ancienne miss france vous
connaissez mieux le dossier que nous en
fait ya un règlement et sais pas si lui
qui décide c'est à la libre appréciation
du comité régional en fait s qui a dû se
passer pour cette jeune fille c'est que
peut-être elle a fait des photos ya
longtemps mais au moment où elle s'est
présentée en 2020 elle n'a pas montré
ses photos de faire d'être disqualifié a
menti c'est là où elle est chez les
photos décliné dans sa démarche parce
que si lé monde un trait est quelque
chose qu elles n'ont rien de choquant
les photos on est là taxes et d'impôts
de sylvie tellier vous non à la
franchise
merci de la réhabiliter peut le faire
c'est canal a pas trop fait ça serait ça
serait désir les gens qu'elle a nommé en
dessous et c'est pas possible parce que
quand tu as l'anarchie basque et a quand
même trop non plus synchrone s'il y
avait eu cette histoire surtout en
guadeloupe où c'est avec cette tuerie
est très jolie ou un peu c'était pour
une cause que l'association des bonnes
fait que c'était pour ce concert du sens
et je sais que ça là ça la dérange et je
sais que le règlement il en train
d'évoluer y adhérer à l'horizon avec
certitude inquiets colère vous aimez
sylvie tellier vous maxime bas où je
n'ai rien contre elle pour faire évoluer
les choses ça suffit la jeune femme n'a
pas fait du porno phare était quand même
à wiesen jolies photos de charme pour un
sourire de coiffures tressées pas de
calais menti oui je m'adresser au comité
régional
la maxime galy qui s'adresse à vous la
s'arracher des balles carrées oui une
femme qui fait est ce qu'une femme à qui
fait des photos de charme
il fait des films érotiques ou même des
travailleuses du sexe est ce que ce sont
des souffles amis de jean moulin je vous
pose vraiment la question où rien texto
d'accord et après on va y répondre at il
pour aller plus loin j'ai fait de la
quête est bien la caricature pour dire
qu'il faut vraiment faire évoluer les
choses et qu en 2020
on est encore sur des règles qui datent
via de l'an 40 il a mangé col il a bien
choisi
[Rires]
malika a expliqué tout avec énormément
de précision et on a tout compris et
j'ai vraiment à partir du moment où elle
a menti
bienne n'a pas dit la vérité même si les
photos sont pas choquant en choquant non
ce qu'on peut se demander si le
règlement est obsolète et skybox il est
obsolète falardeau mais alors qui va
juger les photos mais c'est mais c'est
moi qui cela qui va juger non mais kim a
jugé la nudité est ce que c'est
pornographique est ce que c'est érotique
est-ce que des bandages sur des saints
non mais non mais dans l écriture connu
sais rien moi je pense que le côté
politique le ruban adhésif qu'ils sont
obligés d'interdire les photos de deux
seins nus parce que tout d'un coup ils
vont avoir des castings qui vont se tait
les réaliser avec des nanas très mange
marseillais alors après il va y avoir
des faux seins il va y avoir les
tatouages et au plais à l'épée au gs oui
[Applaudissements]
on y va le comité n'est pas là c'est le
bauhb and the trip hop ça c'est votre
groupe
oui oui vous avez un peu de pouvoir non
j'ai pas mais merci quand vous avez
enfin expliqué aux côtés de miss france
il faut changer les règlements up
attendez c'est pas un petit qui produit
la cérémonie c'est mandy qui contrôle
tout ça c'était assez par une des bonnes
yahia mathieu qui resteront démontable
oui mais n'avait à l'époque pas une
balle à la jambe gauche
bref faites quelque chose c'est de votre
faute abouabou cyril mais au moins il
sait pas ce que tu as dit que tu m'as
[Rires]
dis mamie cash et géré a dit elle n'a
pas menti tout le monde était pas qu'on
sait sont régis du comité s'il monte qui
monte
j'ai participé quand tu t'inscris sont
heureux de main sur des photos
et on scanne boxe oui jean michel moi
personnellement je suis beaucoup plus
choqué par le fixe n'a jamais même pas
dessus de 5 ans
[Applaudissements]
quel l'elysée un programme va parce
qu'on l'a perdu
[Musique]
non non moi j'avais pas vu notre
shopping d'année en plus à balayer on
aura un nouvel avis de boxe mais enfin
c'est qu'à partir du moment où il ya un
règlement alors on respecte les règles
qu'on ait quelque chose à redire ou pas
de ces règles il ya des règles on sait
pertinemment quand on se présente donc
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans sa vie quand
même on est pas on la voit donc à partir
du moment où on sait qu'on a fait des
photos qui pourraient parce qu'on sait
que c'est pas spécialement vulgaire
c'est parce que ça me plaît encore je
dis pas que c'est très fin bref j'adore
mon avis pour aller oui donc on va pas
des sur les questions et vous c'est le
règlement qui vous dérange couture un
règlement long on on les respecte vous
dit tout comme mme anita après les jeux
tu disais que oui on qui est que
j'allais pouvoir juger ben à partir du
moment où on voit ton ainsi battu tu
fais pas le trou alors c'est pas le bon
on peut pas devant lui pas de volume il
va nous faire une suti barre sur le coin
savez si oui la série d'accords je suis
déçu parce qu'il ya un règlement et
qu'ils soient respectés comme le dit
malika en revanche c'est vrai qu'il faut
peut-être que l'assouplir et alors
pourquoi avec de cajoler mais sous la
sopie pour l on voit aussi la sueur je
suis d'accord car pour le coup une photo
pour une très belle chose que là avec
toutes ces photos cette année ça va
évoluer l'année d'avalon jeu